[Musica]
buonasera a tutti mi sono fatta
accompagnare da questa piantina che in
realtà è forse il personaggio più
importante di questo talk quindi adesso
cerchiamo poi di coinvolgerla chi come
me ha avuto è stato bambino all'inizio
degli anni 70
forse si ricorderà con piacere come io
ricordo con molto piacere le domeniche
dei primi mesi del del 1974 quando
improvvisamente nei bambini scoprimmo
che la città poteva avere un volto anche
diverso perché le strade si svuotavano
completamenti mezzi motorizzati quindi
potevamo giocare in mezzo alla strada
alla bicicletta monopattino pattini a
rotelle senza preoccuparci del traffico
anche queste sono foto scattate a
bologna in quegli anni come potete
vedere ci sono alla popolazione ha
vissuto quei momenti spesso con una
sorta di clima da festa popolare tirando
fuori i mezzi di locomozione più più
strampalati il velocipide vedete quel
quel tandem trek non si dice in italiano
oppure sentito anche il modo un po così
provocatorio come la caratteristico di
quegli anni come questo ragazzo che beve
un bicchiere di vino susan tavolino in
mezzo ai ali a porta zamboni immagini
che facciamo fatica a pensare oggi bene
gli adulti di allora è sicuramente i
governi di allora non probabilmente non
ricordano con lo stesso piacere quei
momenti perché tutto ciò era dovuto alla
prima grande crisi economica del secondo
dopoguerra quella che bloccò rallentò
fortemente uno sviluppo ininterrotto che
c'era stato nel secondo dopoguerra il
trentennio glorioso è il motivo per
questo quindi fu legato al fatto che i
paesi del mondo occidentale
industrializzati si trovarono
all'improvviso senza più energia senza
più petrolio per fare andare avanti le
proprie macchine non solo le automobili
ma proprio la macchina industriale
questo per delle scelte economiche ma
soprattutto politiche di paesi
produttori di petrolio che decisero di
bloccare le forniture il mondo
occidentale industrializzato si trova di
fronte a un fatto lampante cioè il fatto
che la propria economia e quindi il
proprio stile di vita era fortemente
condizionato dal petrolio dipendeva
interamente dal petrolio che quindi per
soddisfare il proprio fabbisogno
energetico
noi ci rivolgevamo al petrolio come
quasi
unica fonte di energia qual è la il
fabbisogno energetico dell'umanità oggi
nel 2017 se stimato nell'ordine 17
terawatt 17 terawatt parlando
scientificamente significa 17 mila
miliardi di yahoo
al secondo una quantità di energia
enorme che ne consumiamo al secondo
cerchiamo di capire quanto grande è
questa energia
prendiamo in considerazione un un
fenomeno naturale di grande potenza e
cascate del niagara una delle tre
cascate di negare alla più la più bella
probabilmente questa a ferro di cavallo
bene la potenza di questa che della
cascata in la gara non è tanto
nell'altezza sono solo 50 metri ma nella
larghezza quindi nella portata alla
quantità di acqua che continuamente si
riversa dall'alto nel fiume sottostante
attraverso questa caduta di 50 metri
bene con questi numeri a disposizione il
volume di acqua e di 2 milioni di litri
al secondo e l'altezza l'equazione della
fisica ci permette di calcolare
facilmente la potenza dissipata che
assomma grosso modo a un gigawatt a
celle inerti la potenza caratteristica
di una centrale elettrica di tipo
nucleare o a carbone di media grandezza
grossomodo bene prendiamo questa cascata
e triplichiamo nell'altezza d'accordo da
50 la facciamo diventare 150 metri per
intenderci una volta e mezzo la torre
degli asinelli visto che siamo tutti qua
a bologna non basta prendiamo il fronte
dagli 800 metri della cascata reale la
facciamo diventare lunga 4.700
chilometri quindi la distanza che
intercorre tra boston e seattle in una
cascata del genere la quantità di acqua
che passa in un secondo di 12 miliardi
di litri
d'accordo che equivale grossomodo a
svuotare il lago maggiore in un'ora
d'accordo questa è una cascata di queste
dimensioni clima cascata che si estende
lungo tutto il confine tra stati uniti e
canada che a questa portata così grande
è la quantità di energia che l'umanità
consuma in un secondo corta dove
prendiamo questa energia questa energia
noi la prendiamo per la 87 per cento dai
combustibili fossili ancora oggi 40 anni
dopo la crisi energetica ancora usiamo
per la 87 per cento i combustibili
fossili per alimentare il nostro sistema
quindi carbone gas naturale e petrolio
come prima conseguenza perché noi lo
bruciamo questo queste questi da questi
combustibili li bruciamo come prima
conseguenza produciamo un sacco di
anidride carbonica co2 perché è uno dei
prodotti della combustione non è dire
carbonica che produciamo un anno sono 36
gigatonnellate 36 miliardi di tonnellate
che sono una quantità ragguardevole
giusto per un esempio con una quantità
di gas così a temperatura e pressione
ambiente potremmo riempire un cilindro
che ha come base la cerchia muraria di
bologna come altezza 3.500 km cioè 35
volte l'altezza dell'atmosfera è una
quantità ragguardevole ma non così
grande e tutto sommato se consideriamo
la quantità di co2 che noi produciamo
esseri viventi piante animali esseri
umani continuamente con la respirazione
il problema è che il sistema terra
questa quantità in eccesso non sa
gestirla non riesce ad assorbirla e
quindi si accumula gradualmente
nell'atmosfera e provoca quello che noi
conosciamo come problema del
riscaldamento globale ma questo non è
l'unico punto un altro punto importante
da considerare che il petrolio è una
materia prima
preziosissima che la terra ha prodotto è
accumulato in centinaia di milioni di
anni sotto terra e noi ce la stiamo
allegramente bruciando ok per
riscaldarci per fare andare avanti il
nostro sistema
questa materia prima e preziosissima
perché alla base della sintesi chimica
di tante sostanze e prodotti e materie
che noi usiamo continuamente siete
seduti sulla plastica inutile che ce la
raccontiamo se non ci fosse il petrolio
sareste seduti per terra
quindi non solo la plastica ma i
detersivi e fertilizzante i tessuti su
con cui ci vestiamo le medicine alcune
medicine molte medicine ai vitamine
vengono dal petrolio e persino le
candeline con cui decoriamo la torna la
torta di compleanno dei nostri figli
sono tutti i prodotti del petrolio
quindi noi stiamo allegramente bruciando
una risorsa una materia prima
preziosissima che invece dovremmo
custodire preziose gelosamente per le
nostre per noi e soprattutto per le
generazioni future
però noi di energia abbiamo bisogno dove
la possiamo prendere la risposta è
semplice e sulla nostra testa
tutti i giorni non di notte ma
dall'altra parte ma di giorno e sulla
nostra testa anche se non si vede perché
a bologna spesso è velato o nuvoloso e
così via
il sole inonda letteralmente di energia
la terra si stima che la quantità di
energia a seconda che arriva sulla terra
è dell'ordine di 100 mila terawatt
ricordiamo il 17 ter avanti prima il
rapporto è molto sbilanciato riprendendo
l'analogia della cascata del niagara e
questa è un'immagine che mi che
suggerita da oliver morto nel suo
bellissimo libro sulla geo
ingegnerizzazione il 100 mila terawatt
corrisponderebbe una cascata del niagara
alta non 150 metri ma 10 km e che si
estende lungo tutto intorno alla terra
lungo l'orizzonte lungo l'equatore
quindi immaginate questa cascata enorme
alta 10 km che divide l'emisfero
settentrionale dall'ingv herbert
meridionale attraverso il quale passa in
continuamente un oceano di acqua
questa è la e l'energia che in un
secondo il sole manda sulla terra
va bene quindi la l'uomo d'altra parte
ha già sviluppato delle tecnologie che
sono già mature che sfruttano almeno in
parte questa energia abbiamo in mente
l'eolico e il fotovoltaico bene questo è
un esempio e una è una centrale solare
eolica che si trova in texas cerbino che
da 580 megawatt che può alimentare 157
mila abitazioni questi abbiamo tutti in
mente queste grandi distese che strano
anche in italia sempre più spesso di
pannelli fotovoltaici
questo è un altro esempio è la più
grande fattoria solare del mondo
attualmente in cina longhi ansia e da
850 megawatt quindi sono potenze
ragguardevoli quanto facciamo un fattore
di scala confrontiamo la più grande
fattoria solare fotovoltaica quella
della cina con il fabbisogno mondiale
vediamo che il rapporto di scale 20.000
che è un numero grande ma tutto sommato
non così grande list considerando quante
estesa dalla superficie terrestre
quindi noi potremmo pensare di
alimentare la nostra economia mondiale
utilizzando questi sistemi
eppure per la 87 per cento stiamo ancora
usando i combustibili fossili una
ragione ci deve essere ci sono tante
ragioni ma una regione sicuramente
importante che questi sistemi
tecnologici producono energia elettrica
l'energia elettrica non è il migliore
dei vettori energetici che possiamo
immaginare perché è difficile del
magazine aree da trasportare
chiaramente sarebbe molto meglio avere
dei sistemi di produzione dell'energia
più delocalizzate distribuiti non così
concentrati in grande centrali che
producono l'energia in una forma
fruibile lì dove serve anche nel paesino
sperduto del centrafrica bisognerebbe
pensare a qualche soluzione ci sono
altre soluzioni
bene alcuni di noi molti di noi in giro
per il mondo
pensano che ci siano altre soluzioni che
queste non siano le uniche e sicuramente
non le ultime soluzioni al problema
dell'energia rinnovabile e cosa dobbiamo
fare dobbiamo semplicemente fare un
passo indietro fermarci un attimo e
guardare cosa fa la natura come la
natura risolto il problema della
conversione energetica perché è indubbio
che la natura ha risolto l'energia dello
sfruttamento dell'energia solare perché
la vita sulla terra dipende al 100 per
cento dal sole quindi l'ha risolto
questa piantina con cui ho l'onore di
condividere il palco è il vostro tempo
sa fare questo mestiere molto bene la
sua vita dipende interamente dal sole ma
lei dal sole prendere l'energia che
serve a lei per crescere per riprodursi
e per prosperare come specie e il bello
che lo sa fare anche da un sacco di
tempo non lei poverina perché avrò pochi
mesi di vita
però in generale la sua specie vegetali
sanno sfruttare le già solare per questo
scopo da 2 miliardi e mezzo di anni
perché due miliardi e mezzo di anni fa
comparve sulla terra questo gruppetto di
atomi chimici di atomi li rappresentano
con delle palline colorate sennò ci
perdiamo e le le stanghette bianche sui
legami che legano gli atomi tra di loro
in gergo questa roba si chiama cluster
bene questo classe sta a fare una cosa
molto semplice e la sa fare molto bene
sa catturare una molecola d'acqua questo
classe si trova scusate all'interno
della foglia all'interno delle proteine
che costituiscono il tessuto della
foglia ce ne sono tanti
questo cluster sa catturare una molecola
di acqua e sfruttando l'energia del sole
la spacca rompe i legami che legano
l'ossigeno con l'idrogeno e producono
idrogeno e ossigeno questa reazione
indicata qua sotto
in realtà non è proprio così ma va bene
l'idrogeno è un'altra forma non è gas
nella foglia non si può metodio
un equivalente di idrogeno gassoso il
questa idrogeno che viene fornito
permette di fare la foglia un'altra cosa
pure importante cattura una molecola di
co2 usa l'idrogeno che appena prodotto e
converte la co2 in zuccheri e gli
zuccheri sappiamo che sono l'alimento
delle dei tessuti viventi di noi stessi
anche quindi riassumendo quello che fa
la foglia di prendere due molecole che
si trovano su tutta la terra
dappertutto co2 e acqua due molecole
stabili le prende con l'energia del sole
le trasforma in ossigeno che libera
nell'atmosfera e il glucosio il glucosio
è l'alimento dei tessuti viventi delle
cellule viventi in un secondo tempo
questo blu cose l'ossigeno che ha
prodotto li usa per far funzionare le
proprie macchine interne quindi crescere
riprodursi prosperare vedete che quello
che fa la pianta è una cosa è un
bellissimo circolo virtuoso perché usa
due molecole fa questo questa
trasformazione del già solare in energia
vitale e riporta riproduce le stesse
molecole di partenza quindi è un esempio
perfetto di ray dell'economia circolare
di cui parlava la collega prima ora noi
che cosa possiamo fare con la foglia
artificiale il nostro progetto è quello
di imitare la natura prendere
ispirazione dai meccanismi gli intimi
che fa permettano la foglia di fare
questo questa sorta di miracolo e
riprodurlo artificialmente perché perché
in questo modo noi possiamo metterci il
nostro ingegno e migliorare persino le
soluzione che la natura ha inventato
aumentarne l'efficienza
per risolvere il problema energetico
questo lo facciamo usando di dispositivi
schematicamente infatti così 2 the 22
blocchi 2 due moduli uno che ha la
funzione di assorbire l'energia del sole
e di togliere gli elettroni alla alla
molecola di acqua non tale da rompere i
legami tra ossigeno e idrogeno
producendo ossigeno che si libera e i
protoni h più grossi indicati di sopra
nell'altro modulo i protoni e gli
elettroni estratti dall'acqua vengono
combinati per produrre l'idrogeno
realizzando quindi la reazione di
scissione dell'acqua e produzione di
idrogeno per farlo usiamo delle
nanostrutture di carbonio come questi
illustrate in questa immagine dove
queste palline rosse sono in realtà dei
nano
particelle di metallo sulle quali
vengono proprio queste relazioni
e questi sono i dispositivi niente di hi
tech è un dispositivo che ci sarebbe per
studiare e verificare le proprietà
quindi alla fine latex questa tecnologia
porterebbe uno sviluppo di un'economia
basata sull'idrogeno ma l'idrogeno non è
il migliore dei vettori energetici
perché anche se è difficile da
immagazzinare e trasportare quindi la
nostra idea di passare oltre
fare come fa la foglia produrre dei
combustibili come ad esempio il metanolo
oppure il metano e quindi arrivare di
un'economia basata sulle conversioni e
solare in combustibili ora potrei
lasciarli con questa immagine
no la nostra foglia artificiale un
giorno andrà tante foglie artificiali si
potranno lavorare in sintonia in
sincronia per produrre questi
combustibili ma preferisco lasciarvi con
queste immagini
in realtà perché questa in realtà è lo
stato dell'arte
stiamo ancora al livello del germoglio
la follia la fogliolina appena nata è
perché si arrivi all albero maestoso che
avete visto nell'immagine prima abbiamo
bisogno ancora di tanto lavoro ma
soprattutto il contributo di forze e
idee della generazione di ricercatori
che si sta affacciando adesso al mondo
della ricerca
vi ringrazio per l'attenzione
[Applauso]